good day everyone happy new year and
welcome
i'm jack van horn from the university of
virginia and please allow me to welcome
you to this edition of our 2020 2021
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series
this lecture was supported by uva's
integrated translational health
institute of virginia
the uva brain institute the college of
arts and sciences the school of data
science
and through grants from the national
institutes of general medical sciences
it is my delight and privilege to
welcome our speaker today dr kevin
pelfrey
professor of neurology from here at the
university of virginia
dr pelfrey is a neuroscientist and
expert on brain development
and he is the harrison wood jefferson
scholars foundation professor of
neurology
and also the director of the center for
healthy brain development here at uva
he earned his phd at the university of
north carolina in chapel hill in 2001
and since he's had extensive experience
teaching and conducting research at
leading institutions such as
carnegie mellon at duke university as
well as at yale
before coming to uva dr pelfrey served
as the carbonell
family professor in autism and
neurodevelopmental disorders at george
washington university
as well as the founding director of the
autism and neurodevelopmental disorders
institute
his team seeks to better understand the
causes of autism spectrum disorder
and related neurodevelopmental disorders
to deliver the right treatment to the
right individuals
at the right time kevin is a principal
investigator of the nih
autism center of excellence program in
particular the neurogenetics of autism
network
he's certainly uh uh uh
excuse me he's also served by
appointment of the secretary of health
and human services as a member of the
interagency
autism coordinating committee his
presentation today it
is entitled building precision medicine
for autism
plural as always we are streaming this
lecture live and for recording via
youtube and if you are watching via
youtube
thank you so much for joining us today
also our specially selected 2020 2021
biomedical data science innovation lab
participants
are encouraged to submit any questions
for dr pelfrey by the chat feature in
their zoom sessions
i will personally synthesize these
questions um collect them and ask them
on behalf
on your behalf during the last 10
minutes or so of the lecture
and with that welcome kevin thank you so
much we are very excited to hear your
lecture
thank you thank you very much and thank
you for um
those who are watching um i'm very
excited to do this
excited to view a lot of the other
presentations that are being done i
think it's a great resource
so i'm going to talk about autism today
um and autism is a
condition that currently is behaviorally
defined
think of making a behavioral diagnosis
of autism when we see that a child
or a young person young adult
has qualitative differences in social
functioning
combined with restricted and repetitive
behaviors
and a rigidity of thought that's
characteristic
of autism and when we see those things
together
and a developmental history of those
differences in functioning then you know
we make the call
autism however there's
vast heterogeneity in terms of
functioning
and adaptive behaviors and severity of
symptoms
across a wide spectrum of
autistic people and that makes it very
difficult
to really plan for
the proper interventions and the right
types of treatments that we want to
select and so
you know fundamentally the the fact that
we still rely on
observation and behavioral diagnosis and
developmental history
as opposed to what has happened in other
areas of medicine
where we have more biologically informed
diagnoses that would that refer back to
the cause of the causes of a condition
so we think about the cause and we know
there are multiple causes of autism
and depending on the biological
mechanisms involved you get this
difference in
presentation that we think of as the
heterogeneity
on the autism spectrum so this
this kind of lack of biological markers
and our inability to more precisely
diagnose autism now plural
thinking about the different causes
leads to
a status quo where we have inexact
treatments
we tend to apply the same evidence-based
interventions across the spectrum
and they work better or worse
for different kids for reasons that we
don't really understand
so we have this broad application
of inexact treatments and that can lead
to a lot of wasted time
a lot of failures to optimize progress a
lot of
loss of resources for families who are
paying for these interventions
and um and in general you know
most importantly a lack of of helping
the child and helping the child's family
to optimize the outcomes for the kids
so a lot of the work that i want to show
you today
is aimed at trying to understand
different causes of autism tr and trying
to pursue different biological markers
that might help us directly address
that problem of a lack of
mechanistically informed
indicators and diagnostic instruments
for autism
as well as prognostic indicators
of what would work best for which
kids all right so
something that i want to emphasize from
the outset
is that while our work is translational
in nature
and we're hoping that the work that we
do will have a direct impact on families
it's built upon almost a decade now
of of really basic science that has
advanced our understanding of different
components of
the human brain and how those components
interact
so you know for
in the first editions of the kind of
bible of
of neural science principles of neural
science
there were chapters devoted to cognition
to language to motor function
but little mention of social functioning
which seems
kind of funny now when we think about it
because
you know that's such an important
component of
being human you know how we interact
with other people how we understand
other people's intentions and
how we understand other people's
perspectives but
around you know the late 1990s early
2000s
there was really a revolution in
neuroscience cognitive neuroscience
using different imaging techniques
to start to understand that
there was a chapter yet to be written on
the social brain
and so the concept of the social brain
is that we have dedicated
systems for processing the actions and
intentions of other people
and that we can very rapidly and readily
use these dedicated
systems they're modules but they're
interconnected with
other systems that do other things
language higher order reasoning
executive function even our our action
systems from
promoter responses and they're
they're central to our understanding of
other people and then
informing the rest of our brain as to
what actions or what words we want to
use
in order to respond to kind of a complex
to and fro
with other individuals and one of the
little bits of the social brain
that will feature prominently today just
one component
that plays an important role in
what now is understood as a widely
distributed system
is the superior temporal sulcus region
and this is a part of the brain that
processes
what we call biological or social motion
and
this is a little movie you're seeing now
back in the early 2000s was high-end
virtual reality now it's a little bit of
a joke when we talk about
virtual reality compared to what we can
do now
but it was a simple experiment where we
were showing in
typically developing college students
different types of motion be they you
know people moving
or even a robot moving like a person
compared to
for example a little caricature of a
grandfather
clock or a mixed up
robot that was upside down and the parts
were all mixed up
so that you didn't see it as a person
walking
and what this early study showed was
that
there were regions of the brain
especially along the temporal lobe just
above your
your right mostly in the right
hemisphere just above your ear
that respond quite strongly to
biological motion and are dedicated to
processing that type of motion
but don't respond to other types of
motion and so
that was a early demonstration that
the brain already just in seeing
people moving starts to treat
other people in the environment
differently than it does
other moving objects in the environment
and
other types of visual information coming
in
so it tags it as having special
significance
and applies a whole set of computations
to it
that aren't aren't used for other
stimuli
and what's really striking about this is
that even from
the first days of
postnatal life human infants and
actually a lot of other species
treat the the movements of their species
so humans look at human movement
already from birth very differently than
they do
other types of movement it's as though
they're pre-programmed by a combination
of genetics and prenatal experience
to hone in on that type of
motion and see it as unique and
interesting
and learn from it something that allows
them
to progress through their social
development
so um i'm excited now that
there's actually a chapter on the social
brain and the new
principles of neuroscience textbook
so we've come a long way and it's that
basic
science that really supports our efforts
to
look for biological markers
so one of the earliest studies we did
of children with autism we're putting
them inside the
mri magnet we were taking pictures of
their
brain as they were watching either
coherent biological motion
which is this is a good example of that
so they're watching
these little point light displays
they're called these have been used in
psychology for
many decades to study you know how we
process
and then you know more recently once mri
came along and started to be used
starting to be used a lot
in cognitive neuroscience started using
these stimuli to study social perception
see
in this case you have a person being
filmed
doing patty cake actually a sort of a
child friendly interaction
and then the scrambled biological or
non-social notion
now i'm playing that next to it and
that's just the same exact
um point lights but now scrambled up in
a way that
hopefully no one would recognize as
socially meaningful even though you
might recognize it as
equally somewhat equally interesting
because it's moving around in a kind of
random way
and so we had these two stimuli and we
would show
versions of these different actions and
different scrambled actions
to kids with autism while they were in
the magnet
and we did this study um you know on a
large number of participants over time
and so
at some point we started using the
brain scans that would result from this
in a much more data science oriented way
and we did some machine learning
to see if we could use the patterns of
activity that we would see
from kids watching these different types
of movies across
several different studies so typically
developing kids and
kids with autism to see if we could
go in and start to identify
you know what are the parts of the brain
and
how they're interacting that best
separate individuals with autism from
typically developing individuals in a
diagnostic sense and so we did this
using some machine learning algorithms
where we first had a discovery set so we
had you know
known um the computer you know we were
telling
it okay these are kids
without autism and these are kids with
autism
hopefully you're able to see my mouse
there moving around
and you know we're saying okay learn the
different features of the data set
these imaging voxels
and their activity over time so in
essentially four-dimensional
space including time where we could
differentiate the people the
kids with and without autism and the
computer algorithm is
learning up you know how to do this and
then we used a much
larger replication data set by virtue of
doing
this type of scanning over a long period
of time with many kids
and we said okay you know now we're not
going to give you any hints about
who has the diagnosis and who doesn't
and you want the computer to apply
what it learned and see how well it does
in a new data set and the results i
think were really intriguing
so let me lead you through this so so
panel a
here sorry panel a is showing you the
parts of the brain that best
differentiate
kids uh with and without autism okay
and these are components that we
have come to be called the fusiform face
area fusiform gyrus
lateral fusiform gyrus to be specific
and the part of the brain i already
mentioned this right superior temporal
sulcus region
these were the regions that
statistically speaking did
the best job at differentiating kids
with and without autism now i want to
bring you down to c
here for a moment you notice this says
all boys
and this is a receiving operate operator
characteristic curve and these are often
used to display data
that we want to use for making
diagnostic
decisions in in medicine
and what this is suggesting is that our
model did
quite a real quite a good job on area
under the curve here of 0.77
of differentiating boys with autism
from typically developing boys and
um you know if you're if you're either
expert on this type of data
or you know you're you're carefully
listening to my words you notice i went
from kids with autism to
boys with autism so when you look up
here at panel b
you'll notice that for girls with and
without autism
our model did a terrible job at
differentiating
girls with autism from typically
developing girls
in fact it almost well in fact it did do
worse than chance which is
kind of hard to do either we broke math
or the social brain is
actually um more active and more
connected
in girls with autism than typically
developing girls which is something
we'll
return to in a few minutes and so on the
one hand we were very excited that
we had an example of a potential
biological marker
that could distinguish kids with and
without autism
but on the other hand we were
disappointed that it seemed to only work
for boys and then at the same time
very intrigued as to why it doesn't work
for
girls and this was in the
greater context of findings
within genetics that girls with autism
in order to receive the diagnosis of
autism
needed to have a stronger or larger
genetic hit in order to get to the same
behavioral diagnosis at the same time
in that context was knowledge that
oftentimes girls were going undiagnosed
until later in development
oftentimes whereas the average for
diagnosing a boy with autism let's say
might be
two to three years of age for a girl
was pushed back at least a couple of
years to four or five
and there were many clinical anecdotes
of girls who were really not getting
diagnosed
until the early
late pre-teen early teen years where
they were really facing greater social
challenges at school
that kind of led to them getting in some
disciplinary trouble
and then upon kind of really being
noticed at that point
we're getting the type of diagnostic
care
that led to a diagnosis of autism and it
wasn't that they had become autistic
later
they were always autistic it's just that
our diagnostic process had
had really missed them and they hadn't
been brought to the attention of people
who could do a reliable diagnosis
and so they were the
girls with autism in general are a much
greater
risk for for suffering from
the effects of getting a later diagnosis
and we can go into that a little bit
later as well
beyond the obvious additional
loss of time for intervention as well as
the social isolation
and the social ostracism
that comes along with being different
especially when
you think about girls and boys as they
enter middle school and
kind of make the transition into high
school so
we were on the one hand disappointed on
the other hand
intrigued because of these genetic
findings and these findings of girls
who were being diagnosed late both
because
they were being missed by standard
diagnostic channels
and also suggestions that they were able
to camouflage
their autism and so that kind of relates
back to this notion of doing worse than
chance here
in panel b in the sense that
you know our girls that
have a diagnosis of autism and how do
they become
quite adept at being able to
socially adapt so much so that they're
actually
[Music]
have increased activity so somewhat
suggesting
increased work of the social brain
trying to
fit in and then how does that affect
other aspects of brain development for
them because
you think back to a couple slides ago
when i was talking about how
the typically developing social brain
very effortlessly processes other
people's intentions and their actions
and helps you fit in socially in this
case it's suggesting that
the girls with autism are accomplishing
some of this
but they're they're doing it at a very
high cost
in terms of the energy being devoted
quite literally
to their social brain and you know what
does that
pull away from and how exhausted they
must feel
and how does it perhaps relate to
a very common observation among
studies of girls with autism of
diagnostic comorbidity down the road
where greater rates of depression and
anxiety and eating disorders
in those girls that we we see some of
in boys with autism but nowhere near the
same
type of of comorbidity and levels of
mental illness that we see in the girls
with autism
so
[Music]
on the one hand a good demonstration of
how we can apply
advanced data science techniques to
begin to identify a biomarker
but then suggesting that much more work
needs to be done
in order to begin to identify
you know what is different about girls
with autism and so
the university of virginia is the the
lead site
for a network of locations that
are studying girls of autism they
include some really great
universities including university of
washington at seattle
university of california los angeles
harvard yale
children's national hospital and george
washington university in dc
and of course the university of virginia
and we're studying um
girls with autism across this network
in part because one of the strongest
kind of biological findings
in the field of autism is that autism is
much more prevalent in boys versus girls
now this is true
of all almost all neurodevelopmental
disorders
in the sense that boys truly are
the weaker sex when it comes to
neurodevelopmental
conditions and neurodevelopment in
general we're
much more susceptible to
just about every neurodevelopmental
condition psychiatric condition
um than girls but uh it's even more so
in autism to the extent that we think
about those genetics findings that i
mentioned earlier
that girl development
both genetically and
in terms of brain development and
perhaps social programming
is protective against developing autism
so we needed a network because we needed
to recruit as many girls
as possible in statistics or
epidemiology we call that over sampling
and so we're over sampling for girls
we're also studying boys with autism
we're still interested in boys with
autism in this network of course
but we wanted to over sample for girls
and so what we're doing is a
mixed methods approach so the university
of virginia
in addition to being the administrative
lead of the
network is also the home of the the
data coordinating center and that's
actually led by jack van horn
and what jack is is leading is
where we're recruiting and then
taking biological samples so
blood and saliva and we're taking
electrophysiological data
and we're taking functional magnetic
resonance imaging data
um from all of these kids and then
extensive and actually
i should say they're now young adults
older adolescents and young adults this
is a longitudinal study
what jack's helping us do is bring
together all of that data
so that we can begin to look at the
integration
of different levels of analysis of the
human
organism from genes to brain to behavior
to social context
and understand the bi-directional
interactions within and across those
levels of analysis
over time and then that we hope will
lead to greater insights
into the development of
on one hand kids with without autism and
then
sex differences in those patterns of
development and also sex
differences within patterns of typical
development okay so show you one example
of where we're sort of going with this
this slide is simply showing you that
across our or now fairly large data set
when we look at processing of
social information what we see is that
in boys we again
replicate this finding that their social
brain
is different that they have less
activity and
less connectivity among social brain
regions
in in comparison to typically developing
boys
when we look at girls with autism the
those differences are absent and
relative to typically developing girls
what they have
is much less activity in regions of the
brain
involved in processing higher order
integration of that information so
it seems it almost suggests that they're
sort of using their social brain
using their social brain to
to process this type of information
without
passing it along to higher order
executive prefrontal regions and
more action-oriented regions that would
allow them to use
that lower level social information
um to to begin to process
um that information and use it in
service of their moment-to-moment
interactions
and so that fits very well with you know
how
girls with autism often present which is
that they might be very interested in
social interaction
that's in contrast to many boys with
autism and they might be
good at certain aspects of it but then
can be terrible at
higher more higher level more subtle
aspects of social interaction so they
might overwhelm
a social partner and not know when to
kind of
you know sit back and interact
less and sort of give that to and fro
and
um in that can become you know alienated
and
ridiculed for being socially awkward as
opposed to
um for boys they might present as kind
of uninterested in social interaction
and a lot of times in terms of
kind of standards of behavior for boys
that's much less socially
damaging to one's reputation than being
awkward or bad at it
[Music]
if you kind of follow my meaning there
so
we also began as i mentioned to
integrate
you know gene data so genetic data in
this case whole exome sequencing
and what we did here was look at the
patterns
of brain activity in the regions that
differentiated
girls with autism from typically
developing girls during
social inter social perception and we
looked at that in contrast to
a transcriptome of the human brain that
was available
from studies of brains
in totally separate from the subjects we
looked at
from prenatal development to early
infancy via autopsy
and then what part what genes are
expressed in which parts of the brain
and we made a map that had the overlap
between
brain regions that we identified as
being different in the girls with autism
versus the genes that were expressed
most expressed in those regions of the
brain in early development and that
created
essentially a criteria gene set that
was limited by location
from our fmri data and then we looked
within that
and lo and behold what we found was that
girls with autism were much more likely
to have genetic
hits when we looked at their actual
whole exome sequencing data
in terms of copy number variations
single nucleotide variations
so these subtle genetic changes that
were were meaningful in terms of
affecting a synthesis of a protein
what our data showed was that we could
use the imaging data to put a spotlight
on which
genes that we should be looking at and
then when we turn that spotlight on
we saw this very big difference between
the number of genetic hits among girls
with autism compared to boys with autism
and ultimately what this suggested was
that
sorry about that what this suggested is
that
both at the level of brain function and
the genetics
involved in autism in genetic i should
say genetic involved
genetics involved in autism the genes
that
drive girl autism might be very
different
than the genes that drive boy autism and
the way we got to that discovery
was using the imaging data to focus in
on which
genes we should be paying careful
attention to
and we're excited to see that both
within
our data set and then when we went to
a totally different data set in this
case
the simon simplex collection we were
able to replicate that finding in the
simon simplex collection so we had not
only
in our ace network data evidence of this
a discovery of this but then we had a
replication of it
in a totally new data set which of
course
is is a critically important step
for for anything in science but in
particular when
we're thinking about the number of leads
within autism that
we've seen in our lab and all other you
know other labs as well
that then don't pan out in a new data
set
it was particularly um heartwarming that
we
you know could see this in a new data
set so excited about that
now i focused on
social behavior social perception but
that's not the only
story within the field of autism in
terms of trying to understand
what's going on what's different in the
brains of people with autism
it's really just the lens through which
my group has looked most carefully
another approach to this is is an
entirely data-driven approach where we
don't really apply
any preconceived theory but we say okay
let's let's let the brains tell us
what's going
what's going on what's different one way
to do that is through resting state data
and so resting state is exactly what it
sounds like you put the person into the
mri machine
you you help them relax you know and you
tell them
either close your eyes and just kind of
zone out or
keep your eyes open and look at a little
crosshair on the screen
so we're sort of controlling um you know
what they're doing
and just letting their brains kind of
wander
and we measure activity over time and
the correlation between different
regions of the brain
and we did that in this case
and then we said okay what are the
underlying latent
network organizations that best
identify girls with autism from
typically developing girls
and boys with autism from typically
developing boys
and that gave us essentially two maps of
the brain
and differences in the brain and then
that and these were statistical maps in
these three dimensions that said okay
this part of the brain this set of
coordinates
is showing a nice difference between
boys with and without autism over here
this is a part of the brain that shows
the difference of girls with
autism we could take that data that
spatial organization
and look in a resource that's online
it's called neuroscience which is a it's
a really cool
website in a sense that you can type in
you know three-dimensional coordinates
of
the brain and it will tell you um
it will query all of the available
imaging studies that have been
mined and for this database and tell you
you know what
constructs in psychology
have been talked about you know so if
you put in a coordinate
that corresponds to broca's area for
example
in the inferior frontal gyrus
it'll come back with a whole list of
studies that have talked about
that part of the brain in terms of
producing speech
and perhaps mirror neurons as well
and it will rank order the constructs
based on how many studies and what
level of statistical significance
was found within those studies for that
region
corresponding to that construct and for
us this was exciting because we could
submit our maps
and get essentially a diagram
of what constructs map onto
the different latent networks that we
had identified that best defined
autism and girls versus autism with boys
and then we turn that into you know
what's commonly called
a wordle or word olds these days and
what you're seeing on screen now
the top outlined there in pink is the
wordle
for the girls their network to construct
mapping and the size of the font
the you know the size of the words
corresponds to the statistical
significance of the finding
and then you can see the same thing for
boys
below it outlined in blue there and for
boys
that this comes as no surprise to anyone
who
thinks a lot about autism studies autism
you know
that certainly at the core of the
behavioral definition of autism
is differences in social perception in
language comprehension
and person perception and of course
those are the most significant
constructs that that popped out of this
analysis
but the data from girls actually really
stunned us
in the sense that we had to go pretty
far down the list before we found
anything that corresponded to
a similarity with boys language
comprehension being
really the only one and the the
strongest relations
in terms of constructs were anxiety and
emotional regulation
and these aren't um core characteristics
of autism this isn't
you know you don't need to have anxiety
and emotional regulation difficulties
for example
in order to receive the diagnosis of
autism
but for girls oftentimes it's problems
with anxiety
and difficulties in emotional regulation
that
get them to be seen by the proper
clinicians who are able to make an
autism diagnosis
and as far as parents are concerned
across
boys and girls anxiety and emotional
regulation
differences are often the
and difficulties are often the things
most cited
as being most problematic this is
commonly referred to
as autistic meltdowns that are happening
well beyond
the developmental stage where meltdowns
are appropriate
and they cause a lot of trouble for the
individual
and the family in general especially as
the individual gets older
might be physically stronger and more
imposing
these are the kinds of things that get
young people in trouble
and so this is um
was quite striking to us and really gave
us pause in the sense that
what the data was telling us what the
brain activity was really telling us is
that the
underlying circuits that are different
in girls with autism are different
from the differences in boys with autism
and that you know kind of at a first
pass even though it's by no means
perfect
um we could begin to think about autism
being reflected in the brain very
differently for boys and girls
and that should have obvious
implications
for how we approach intervention and
treatment and you know this broader
concept of precision medicine
precision intervention so
next thing i want to show you um is is
an
application of that concept of precision
medicine
having talked a lot about differences
between boys and girls i want to put
that away for a minute
and turn back to a broader focus of
autism in general
and i want to show you an example of
where we've taken
a well-known evidence-based behavioral
intervention it's called
pivotal response treatment the details
of the intervention are
so important just knowing that we
weren't
interested in in determining whether or
not pivotal response training
is a is an effective intervention we
already knew it was
based on the literature but we wanted to
know could we use
imaging to understand how it works
you know what what does it change in
terms of
the developing brain and
can we begin to predict for whom it will
work okay
and what i should tell you about pivotal
response training
like almost every behavioral
intervention for autism
it's a very time consuming and often
extremely
expensive especially if insurance isn't
paying for it
intervention that requires quite a bit
of commitment and time
from the family you know typically
speaking in our case
we gave children 16 weeks
of um of pivotal response training prt
for short and about 25
to 30 hours a week so very intensive
some of that was done
in our laboratory at the um at the el
child study center
and some of it was done in the home and
so this required a parent to bring
that it would usually mom to the young
child study center
or make their home open to us
[Music]
meaning that the parent and the child
were there and you started thinking
about this something that could be very
expensive you know
you think about a 16 week course of prt
it would be costing a family if they
were paying without insurance about 30
000 for the intervention
for with insurance it would be less but
still a substantial
financial commitment we were giving it
for free
because it was for research but if you
think about that that's really
that's quite a burden and it requires
one parent to be available
you know 20 30 hours a week which means
that parent
really can't hold a full-time job and of
course
for many families there is only one
parent so
you think about all of that the stakes
of being able to predict
which kids will benefit from a given
intervention
become very high you know it's not just
an academic exercise
if truly we can do a good job at
predicting
then we can do something very very
meaningful for families
so this is a complex slide i'm going to
unpack it
the first thing i want you to look at is
the different lines on this graph
showing pre
and post and the measurement here is
this
the level of social symptoms measured by
the social
responsiveness scale for each individual
child who is in this study
each child is is a black line here
and this is coming into the study their
level of symptoms
and this is after 16 weeks of
intervention their level of symptoms
and what this is showing is a degree a
high degree of heterogeneity
in how well the kids respond to
pivotal response training so you see
that some of them
changed very very little
going up higher is
is worse it's more symptoms
so if they're responding to the
treatment well
you see they start here and they go down
in terms of level of symptoms so some
kids responded very well
some really didn't respond at all and a
few got a little bit worse
which is common in all clinical trials
and then the red line is the mean and
when we say evidence-based intervention
usually what we mean is
that on average kids get better
have fewer symptoms are doing better
our primary outcome measure and that of
course was true here
but think about all this heterogeneity
for some kids this was a waste of time
and and for their parents as well and
maybe even an intrusion and so
thinking about this slide now we look at
the
using these machine learning techniques
to identify
the parts of the brain that best respond
and best predict whether or not
an individual will do well so best
divi the parts of the brain that really
best help us understand the cytogeneity
these are four clusters of activity that
help
do that and so cluster one is in the
posterior superior temple sulcus
and that's a region mentioned several
times it's involved in really
indicating and processing other people's
actions and intentions
this is a region of the brain in the
parietal cortex that's involved in
distributing and maintaining a tension
a region of the insula and ventral
medial prefrontal cortex that are
in the sorry ventral lateral prefault
cortex it's involved cluster three
widely known to be involved in emotion
regulation and being able to
regulate your behavior to to engage in
an ongoing activity and this last
cluster here
the ventral striatum and the amygdala um
very sensitive to reward including
social rewards of
finding and social interaction rewarding
and what this is saying is that to the
extent that these brain regions are
active and connected in terms of their
activity
the child will do better that's what
this graph is showing
in pivotal response training now a lot
of times
when i talk about this data
if there are clinicians in the audience
they'll kind of say
yeah so you just told me that if a child
can notice social information and pay
attention to it
and if they can regulate their behavior
and
interact with me and if they find it
rewarding
they'll do well in the the intervention
that you're talking about and that seems
kind of obvious
it's like yes but
i'm doing two things that that
that are deeper than that simple
observation
one is these are quantitative measures
that vary by child of levels of
those constructs that we just mentioned
in passing
that really don't have
a reliable and sensitive measure out
there
in nature that can be used by a
clinician to make a decision
and in fact when we looked at all of our
behavioral data
and all of our clinician ratings
we found that that data in contrast to
the brain data
just did a terrible job of predicting
which kids
would benefit from the treatment and one
of the simplest things we did was ask
expert clinicians do you think this
child is a good candidate for this
treatment can you estimate how well
they'll respond
and there's some there's funny things
that happen within cognitive
cognitive psychology talks about these
extensively
that when you're an expert in something
it becomes it can become very
challenging for certain
reasons because of cognitive biases
to make a judgment about a particular
case
and and so actually our imaging
approach was doing a much better job
than even
some of the very best clinicians in the
country when they reviewed the files and
saw
videos of these kids and sometimes met
them in person
being able to predict so we're doing a
very good job
of predicting and that's fine
but we were also showing quite
literally parts of the brain that if
they were
active and connected during the
intervention
if we ramped them up prior to the
intervention
the hypothesis that we're putting
forward is that that
would actually allow us to be able to
turn a kid who wouldn't have been a good
responder
into a good responder and that for us
was very very exciting
so last thing that next the last thing
that i want to show you
is another study separate study that we
did where we used
oxytocin which is a molecule that
affects social behavior and it's known
to affect the social brain we
gave it to kids with autism and what
we're able to show this is a
double-blind placebo-controlled study
we're able to show that there was a high
degree of overlap between the areas of
the brain
that a single dose of oxytocin
would activate and make more
interconnected
relative to placebo there was a high
degree of overlap between those parts of
the brain and the parts of the brain
that predict
good outcomes and good response to
pivotal response training
and so you can sort of see where we're
going with this is that perhaps we've
got
an approach where imaging can allow us
to use a pharmacological agent a very
targeted way
for kids who don't have the activity
that they need to take part in
pivotal response training successfully
to give it to them to
boost their response to the pivotal
response training for example
and we think this can apply to any
evidence-based intervention but
right now we're actually studying this
with funding from the simons foundation
to see if we can
indeed take those kids who don't have
the activity initially and help boost it
nice to mention that now we've been
talking about
kids broadly and what i'm really talking
about
is is four five six year olds and above
but of course autism is a condition
that we can see evidence of very very
early in development so
ultimately we want to push back our
ability to study
the precursors and the biological
markers of autism
to the earliest points possible and so
we're using a lot of measures in
addition to fmri
um where we're able to scan babies but
we're not able to routinely scan babies
it's not
trivial we can't sedate them and so
we're
waiting for them to fall asleep and then
get
images of their brain in order to allow
us to do some of this precision
medicine approaches we have other
techniques including optical imaging and
electrophysiology
that allow us to go in and study some of
the same
concepts with a child who's active
and attending much much younger than
we're used to studying
so the last thing i want to show you
this is actually being led up by
megan puglia who is a an expert in
working with very young infants
and she's working with the neonatal
intensive care unit
team here at uva and where what we're
hoping to do
is is really begin to take some of the
techniques that we have
in some of the eeg signatures that she
has
electrophysiology and apply it to even
very very young
infants and there we're not necessarily
predicting what interventions
would work but rather can we
predict a diagnosis of autism much
sooner earlier in development so that we
can begin to
to develop interventions for even very
young infants
so that we can start to affect the
developmental trajectory
and prevent it from going towards an
autistic trajectory
even before the onset of obvious
symptoms
and so leave you there hopefully
it generates um some questions and
just one last slide to thank the funders
of this research
and of course the families who have made
this possible by
allowing us to to study their kids and
to
meet their kids and take these brain
images i'll stop there for questions
thank you so much kevin that was
fantastic
autism is such a challenging disorder
and i mean one of the things which was
clearly evident is that what we've been
doing
up with just you know a clinical
assessment
up until fairly recently has really been
inadequate to
tell the difference between boys with
autism and girls with autism in
particular
and you mentioned something about the
genes for
girls possibly being different than the
genes for boys
with autism what do we know about the
genetics
of asd in the context of it's it's
clearly not
one gene maybe it's multiple genes may
if they're sex
linked at all perhaps that's explanatory
what do we know about that and
maybe you can explain some of that sure
so
as you mentioned that there's no one
gene that's been discovered that
you know causes autism every time um
when it when it's um different
or present or absent
bigger or smaller but there are
a number of genes that increase the risk
for developing autism
and every time i say the number
it's tomorrow it'll grow but i think the
numbers around
about 100 right now of high confidence
autism candidate genes that separately
or in combination greatly increase the
risk for developing autism
and in addition um so those are kind of
high penetrant genes and then in
addition
there are many many genes that
contribute to risk in sort of the
background
of common genetic variation
that taken in isolation
really don't increase the risk of autism
but when you start
putting certain common genetic variation
together
in certain patterns and then possibly
combine it with
rare genetic variation that is much more
likely to directly cause autism you get
this
this um tapestry
of many genes it could be
hundreds or thousands that then
give you you know a much increased risk
for autism and even then
it's not deterministic so you could have
a lot of autism
risk genes and still not develop autism
you could have
one autism risk gene and develop autism
and so it's it's non-deterministic
and very very complex and then overlay
on that the fact that
some of those genes are sex-linked
and then that some of those
genes play different roles in
brain development depending upon
whether they're in
a boy brain or a girl brain
and the different genetic background of
boys and girls so not necessarily sex
linked per se but
in the milieu of what
genes do depending on whether they're
in the presence of female or male brain
development and the hormonal
milieu going on that
you get an even more complicated picture
so for example
at first blush from our data the genes
that
seem to be hits and candidate genes for
boys with autism and autism in general
are related to synaptic development to
pruning of synapses
to glial development as well
whereas in girls with autism
a lot of what we're seeing in terms of
the gene modules gene expression modules
that we're finding
seem to be more involved with
inflammatory response
and um and control and regulation of
that inflammatory response
that's super interesting so as we kind
of
reaching the top of the hour here i'm
curious of your your thoughts on are
there any
data resources that are available for
people who would want to
say take a look at some of these
different data types that you mentioned
and
finally just what's the role of data
science in helping to
make progress understanding autism
disorder
spectrum disorders yeah yeah sure so
you know one data resource of course is
our network
and you know since we're the data
coordinating center
and jack you're the lead of that
being able to collaborate on that data
get access to the de-identified data and
utilize it for different projects
is fairly straightforward in addition
there's more broadly what's called the
well i call it indar jack remind me of
what it's now
called was the the nih data archive
thank you thank you used to be called
the national database for autism
research and it was autism
focused now it's broader so they changed
the name but it still contains
the autism data from i don't know
many many studies funded by nih that
have contributed to this
are required to contribute to this
archive is condition of the
grant funding and so you can find
incredible
you know wealth of data in that
archive that can be used and integrated
different data types linked by
an individual unique identifier
that's that's still private but will
allow you to know
which individual the data came from and
then there
also are european similar data sets that
are available
eu aims is one i can't speak to how open
it is as a resource but it's it's there
so those are three at least
and you know data sets that are that are
readily
mineable and in terms of the role of
data science you know it
it's absolutely essential um
any of the methods that i sort of
flashed on the screen you know eeg
fmri behavioral data
that we collect clinical data genetics
each of those can tell you some cool
things in isolation
and of course data science techniques
are used
i highlighted machine learning several
times there
but really it's the cross data
formats interactions
that data science is so good at
generating
and handling the giant data sets and
bringing together the different types
to inform much more advanced biological
questions
that where data science shines and is
essential
to this endeavor you know so otherwise
it would just be
silos of researchers working using their
method
and publishing the next paper that's
kind of logical extension
and that's important and fine but it's
the
bridging across all of those different
silos and bringing together the data to
to address advanced questions that is
driving the field forward
and going after the most important
concepts
well thank you so much kevin for sharing
with us
your research and your vision for the
study of autism spectrum disorder
it is clearly a complex
neuroscience challenge data science is
clearly required to sift through and
integrate
these multiple different data types and
i i hope that some of our uh
participants in our foundation or our
sorry a biomedical
data science innovation lab activities
will look to this as a potential
uh project idea um anyway
thank you very much kevin very much
appreciate it
thank you everybody who tuned in and uh
we'll look forward to seeing you next
week
thanks so much enjoy your weekend okay
thank you